body and dash camera video show what led
up to an officer-involved shooting in
Texas after a suspect allegedly shot a
doctor at a medical clinic before
leading police on a short Chase
[Music]
just after noon on July 25th officials
say 34-year-old Brian Mcgee went to
Methodist Family Health Center in Cedar
Hill Texas after making threats to his
girlfriend officers say he planned to
shoot her but instead shot a doctor
after that he drove off
Chrysler
[Music]
um
body camera video shows Cedar Hill
police officers spot McGee's vehicle and
chase after him you have a rifle inside
he had a rifle inside right in that
color
picture
McGee's car came to a stop just two
blocks from the medical center video
shows officers calling for him to drop
his weapon
instead officials say McGee opened fire
Jordan
officials on the scene recovered
multiple weapons including a
semi-automatic rifle a shotgun a pistol
and additional ammunition right now it's
still unclear which weapon McGee used to
shoot at officers
McGee now faces charges of attempted
capital murder of a peace officer an
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
following the shooting he's now in
critical condition the doctor though was
treated for his injuries and has since
been released from the hospital
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie